Speaker 1: Let's now take a look at the flavor
of what's going on in some congressional races
among Republicans. And I will tell you, it is
absolutely sick. Last night, Republicans debated
in the New Hampshire first district, in
the New Hampshire first district race.
There were five Republicans up on the stage.
Four of them said they would impeach Joe Biden
on day one. You know what? Impeach him for what?
Well, that they don't agree on. You really have
to see this. And this is really indicative
of the brazen, partizan, unhinged nature of
the Republican Party at this point in time. You
are going to hear in a moment from Tim Baxter,
Carolyn Levitt, Russell Prescott and Gail Hough
Brown, all of whom are ready to impeach Joe Biden
the day they get into Congress if they do.
Now, the fifth Republican here, Matt Mowers,
he's not ready to say impeach yet, but
he certainly thinks we need hearings
to figure out whether to impeach Joe Biden.
I know it's extraordinarily disturbing.
It's extraordinarily sad. Let's take a listen.
Speaker 2: Would you vote to impeach President
Biden for anything he's done
so far in office? Absolutely.
Speaker 3: Carol. Yes, the dereliction of duty
at our southern border. He's allowed foreign
invasion of our country. He is.
Speaker 1: Now, remember,
almost nothing has changed at the
southern border from Trump to Biden,
other than as the pandemic eased, more people
started to try to come to the United States. There
has been and some families have been reunited
that were separated under Trump. There has been
no real change. But these Republicans want you to
think there's been some 180 at the border trade.
Speaker 3: His oath to the Constitution and
our homeland is a frown. The commander in
chief has one job to protect Americans at home
and abroad. And he did not protect Americans in
Afghanistan. That was the day I got into the race.
Speaker 1: So remember that the they don't know.
They're not sure why. They don't agree on why.
But they know Biden needs to be impeached. One,
it's because of what he did at the southern
border. Oh, well, actually, no, it's because
of what he did in Afghanistan, which, by the way,
is the same thing Trump would have done. Right.
Speaker 2: That's three for three counsel,
Prescott. Yes, I would. Four. Four. And you
do have to have hearings to look into these
things. The fact that you had the president
as secretary of defense, lying to the American
people about intelligence reports coming out of
Afghanistan has to be looked into. Would you?
Speaker 1: So four out of five say yes,
I would impeach on day one. I would vote to
impeach now. And number five out of five says,
I've got to do hearings. We must do hearings
in order to figure out whether to impeach.
Oh, boy. So it's the border, it's dereliction of
duty. It's Afghanistan, or it's just not really
clear why. Understand that we have an economy
right now that is essentially at full employment.
We have consumer demand for all sorts of products
and services off the charts. Demand for doctors
is off the charts. Demand for electricians is off
the charts. Demand for plumbers is off the charts.
Demand for car detailing is off the charts. We are
out of Afghanistan, which Trump was going to do.
Two jobs reports in a row with significantly
greater than expected jobs numbers. Gas declining
26% over a two, two and a half month period,
as rapid a decline as we have ever seen in gas
prices. Inflation coming down with an inflation
report coming out Tuesday, which I expect is going
to be a pretty, pretty good Inflation Reduction
Act, a pact. I could go on and on and on. And the
absolute political theater taking place among the
Republican Party has four out of five Republicans
outright saying, I would impeach him right now
and a fifth saying, well, we should at least
look into it with some hearings. And the most
important takeaway here, as you know, there's
the optics of the cartoonish nature of this.
And that is not something to be ignored. It is
cartoonish and it's a joke. But there's a bigger
story here that is a broader Republican story.
What is the policy vision for the Republican
Party that they've articulated? I would ask
over the last six months, over the last two
years, over the last six years, increasingly,
there is no policy. It's we've got to stop
Marxism. We've got to stop woke. We've got to
impeach Biden. It's dereliction of duty there.
The country is going to hell is Donald Trump.
You'll hear him on Indian TV. This is going to be
a rare treat for you on Indian TV. Donald Trump
saying the country is going to hell and it's all
about appeasing the most extreme unhinged elements
of their party. And I want to remind people,
the New Hampshire First District, in fact,
I want to be accurate about this New Hampshire
First District 2020 presidential results.
In the New Hampshire first congressional district
in 2020. This was a. Uh. Trump won it in 2016,
but then Biden won it quite easily. Yeah, Biden
won it by six in 2020. This is not like an extreme
district. Now, these are Republicans. I understand
the Republicans. There may be extreme. This is
a this is a district that voted Biden pretty
handily for what's considered a purple state,
New Hampshire, in 2020. And yet they are still
kowtowing to the most extreme elements of the
Republican Party. Will that work in the general?
I mean, probably not. But it is political theater
all meant to appease their dear orange leader. And
it's pathetic. I want to remind you that on 919
we are doing a 19 themed membership special.
If you've been thinking, Well, David,
I kind of like the show. I like the idea of the
bonus show, regardless of what Alex Jones says.
Speaker 4: Oh, the bonus show where you
want to make money, everybody else that
makes money to fund themselves is bad, right?
Speaker 1: If that has tickled your fancy,
but you're just waiting for the right moment
to strike. Get on my mailing list at David
Pakman dot com and on 919 you'll get a beautiful
email, a perfect email telling you how to avail
yourself of an extraordinary membership discount.
We'll take a quick break and be right back.